people often say that something called
quantum entanglement is the reason
that quantum computers work as if that's
super obvious
but i started my phd with the aim of
disproving that theory because i hated
it so much
some research i did though convinced me
that i was probably wrong about
entanglement
after all so what are quantum computers
they're just like computers that we're
used to but instead of following the
ordinary rules of physics
they can also take advantage of some
spooky quantum effects
that might sometimes help them perform
some calculations
faster one of the most well-known of
these spooky quantum effects is
something called entanglement
entanglement means that the state of one
part of the quantum computer over here
is inextricably tied up to the state of
the other part of the computer over
there
for example if this quantum bit is in
state 0
then this other qubit is in the state b0
if the first qubit is in state 1 then
the other qubit ends in state b1
but of course in quantum mechanics you
can have both of these
at the same time but that leaves the
second qubit in a rather awkward spot
what's its state is it b0 or b1
entanglement says that it doesn't make
sense to talk about the states of the
individual qubits at all
instead you can only talk about the
state of the entire computer at once
quantum computers can perform some and i
mean a pretty limited number
of tasks better than normal computers
can
this quantum advantage has to be due to
some
quantum effects but which ones actually
matter
people often claim that entanglement is
the quantum effect
that makes quantum computers better in a
quantum computer you have a bunch of
quantum bits
and you let them interact in pairs
at the end you measure the qubits and
hopefully this result will tell you
something useful
entanglement allows the information to
spread a bit faster through the system
than if you had an equivalent setup with
a normal computer
but this argument isn't that complete
because so far we've only shown that
entanglement makes the information
spread
a little faster in limited situations
the size of the speed up that we've been
able to pin to entanglement
isn't anywhere near as big as the size
of the speed up for quantum computers in
general
so this hand waving argument even though
it is somewhat plausible
isn't the reason that a lot of quantum
computing experts believe
entanglement is doing something
important the main reason
is a seminal paper in the field called
on the role of
entanglement in quantum computational
speed up in the paper
the authors come up with a very elegant
way to show that if you don't have
entanglement in your quantum computer
your computer would be useless
more precisely what they showed is if
you have a quantum computer without any
entanglement
then if it's solving some sort of
problem a regular computer can also
solve that same problem
in roughly the same amount of time this
is called
a classical simulation because a normal
computer
is simulating the quantum one here's how
that simulation of an entanglement free
computer works
what you need your normal computer to do
is have a representation of the quantum
computer
at all times like what the quantum
computer is doing
but storing the state of a quantum
computer is usually hopelessly difficult
remember that when there's entanglement
you have to resort to saying things like
if qubit 1 is doing this then qubit 2 is
doing that
otherwise it's doing something else if
qubit 2 is doing something then qubit 3
is doing something else
and you see that it gets really
complicated and it takes
way too much memory to store all this
stuff
in fact to store the information for n
of these qubits
you'd need roughly two to the power of n
unique numbers
to write the state your computer just
can't store that much information in
memory
and so your simulation is just not going
to work
what this paper pointed out though is
that when you don't have entanglement
this state magically simplifies you can
describe
each of the qubits separately because
they don't depend on each other
qubit 1 is in state a qubit 2 is in
state b
etc the memory you need is linear
suddenly this classical simulation is
possible whatever this quantum computer
without entanglement
can do your laptop can too by simulating
it
that's why without entanglement a
quantum computer
is useless okay so far i've given you
the arguments for why
entanglement might be the key feature of
a quantum computer
but now i'm going to tell you why i
found all of that unconvincing
in fact the thing that i was worried
about is pointed out in that original
paper itself
they have this great discussion section
about whether their result shows that
entanglement is the key resource for
quantum computers
they caution against concluding that
because they're worried that this result
is an artifact of the maps that you use
to describe a quantum computer
see in physics you have the actual
object that's real
and that's there and you want to
describe it but then you have to make up
some mathematical description of it
but the thing is not the same as its
description
how can we say that for sure well
because there's often many
different mathematical descriptions for
the same object
when we describe quantum computers we
can write their states in the way that
i've been showing you
and if we do that then yes removing
entanglement is
the thing that hugely simplifies these
states and makes it tractable to
simulate
but we could have written the state
another way for example
this which is called the stabilizer
formalism
then restricting something else in this
case the number of non-poly stabilizers
is what makes the state dramatically
simplify
but now it looks like having non-poly
stabilizers is the key resource of
quantum computing
what you actually want is something that
looks important
independent of what mathematical
formulaism you use to describe the
quantum computer
so entanglement may be what's important
but it may just be an artifact of the
formalism that we chose
in that original paper though they
propose a great test
for whether entanglement is important
that's along these lines
they propose finding out if noisy
quantum computers
need entanglement so what is a noisy
quantum computer
it's really just a normal quantum
computer but one that's experiencing
noise
from the outside world corrupting its
results somewhat but like why would you
be interested in studying these things
because strangely the mass of noisy
quantum states
looks very different from the maps that
we used for noiseless quantum states
this is important because entanglement
also looks
very mathematically different for these
two types of states
if you take a generic noisy quantum
state and you remove the entanglement
the state doesn't suddenly become simple
in fact it doesn't seem to simplify
much at all so in their paper the
authors suggest that perhaps it's
possible to take a noisy quantum
computer
without entanglement and still get a
quantum advantage
if that's true it would be huge because
it would conclusively show
that entanglement isn't the key thing
that makes quantum computing happen
that paper came out in 2003 two years
later
scott anderson put out a list of
semi-grand challenges for quantum
computing
and he put deciding whether noisy
quantum computers
without entanglement are classically
simulable on the list
he thought that we would make progress
on the questions on this list
in five to six years but almost 10 years
after that original paper came out
i started my research in quantum
computing and got obsessed with this
still
unanswered question i just spent half a
year out of university
learning quantum mechanics on my own and
i was really excited about stuff like
entanglement and i enrolled in a physics
research year
i read this list of proposed research
topics and i saw one investigating the
role of entanglement
in noisy quantum computers and i signed
up straight away
my supervisor was an expert on a
particularly
strange type of noisy quantum computer
called the one
clean qubit model this computer is
bizarre
it uses a whole bunch of qubits that are
so noisy
that you have no idea what they're doing
usually
that would make them useless but you're
allowed to have
one clean uncorrupted qubit
that can interact with all these noisy
qubits amazingly
this one good qubit manages to make the
noisy qubits a lot more useful than
you'd expect
there are some things that this computer
can do better than a normal computer
i'll get to what those are in a little
bit but the other remarkable thing
about this computer is how little
entanglement it uses
it had been shown that there is no
entanglement at all
between the clean qubit and the noisy
qubits
that's nuts because if you buy the story
that entanglement is the key to quantum
computing
because it helps shuttle information
around faster then this is hard to
explain
information flow between these two parts
of the computer seemed
critical and yet entanglement isn't
helping at all
there's still entanglement in the rest
of the computer just not
between these two parts so we have this
quantum computer where
it seems like entanglement is not making
itself useful
but the computer is still working anyway
so
the idea was why don't we remove the
entanglement entirely
if we could show that this thing without
entanglement
still has an advantage over a regular
computer then
we have shown that entanglement isn't
crucial for a quantum computer
after all that was the idea
unfortunately
people had had this idea before and
hadn't made a huge amount of progress on
it
and neither did i my supervisor very
wisely told me that i should switch to
something that i could actually get a
paper out of in that year
but i was just a little bit too obsessed
with this thing to let it go
so i achieved nothing but when i was
deciding what to do next
i saw that one of the authors on that
original entanglement paper
was giving a master's class in the uk on
quantum computing
and i decided to go and learn from him
it turns out he's
really knowledgeable and also super nice
because he took me on as a phd student
so proving this result was the main
thing that i wanted to show
in the first year and a half of my phd
though i didn't work on this problem
but i did learn a bunch of fancy new
tools that had come out
that i thought could come in handy for
it once my first project was all wrapped
up
i returned to the one clean qubit model
and roped in a friend to work with me on
it
here's the state of the one clean qubit
model
and this here is an exponential sum so
the amount of information you'd need to
store
in your computer to simulate it would be
huge
now this is what i'd proved that the
state looks like without entanglement
this is still an exponential sum that
still looks pretty hard to simulate to
me
of course though that's not a proof that
it is in fact hard
as i explained before there's always
more than one way to write a state
mathematically
and in some other form it could
potentially simplify
down but i doubted that and so we tried
to prove that there really was no way to
do it
we worked on this thing for ages and got
nowhere but are still
totally convinced that you could prove
that this
state could not be simulated it was one
beautiful counter example that turned
things around
i was in my office thinking about a very
small one clean qubit computer
with only two dirty qubits what this
computer does
is this this u here is a four by four
matrix with
four eigenvectors and each of these has
an eigenvalue
you don't need to know what those terms
mean for this story but
if you're interested i'll link to a
great video explaining it
anyway each time you run the computer it
would randomly choose
one of these four eigenvalues and give
it to you that's what the computer does
that's what the one clean qubit model
does i'd proved that this computer has
no entanglement if and only if the
eigenvectors of the matrix have no
entanglement
but that didn't really tell me what you
had to look like
so i turned around and i asked my office
mate flo
who was also a phd student in the group
what he thought he walked up to the
whiteboard and he wrote down an example
that i hadn't considered
that example changed everything because
one
it was clear how it generalized and two
i knew how to simulate it
yes the simulation was for a very small
example
but it convinced me that i could make it
work in general
not that it was easy it took months of
doing examples
categorizing everything that could
happen into cases
proving things for each of those cases
realizing i'd messed it up and having to
start again
months and months of that and the
pressure was huge
see usually for a phd you don't try and
just do one big project
the advice is to do many smaller
projects that way you can learn lots of
different areas and when some of those
projects inevitably
fall through you have backup plans it's
normal to have
three projects in a phd in the uk in my
field
but some people have as many as 12. i
had
one project under my belt at this point
and i'd started maybe
half a dozen other projects in my second
year but
most had fallen through or i'd lost
interest in them because i was so
focused on this project
and i didn't really have time for other
things but so many times
while i worked on this entanglement
project and i found a flaw in the proof
it felt like the whole thing was
unraveling
and that i'd have nothing to show for my
phd
and that i wouldn't graduate i remember
how intense it was
i worked hard on it every day and i'd go
home some of those days and just
cry because i didn't think it was gonna
happen it was
bad finally finally though i had this
super intense few days where i sat down
and just wrote out the proof start to
finish my co-author and i
checked that proof thoroughly and it
seemed to finally hold water and so
we published it on the physics archive
the response to the paper was so
unexpected i didn't think anyone cared
about this question anymore because
there hadn't been any work on it for so
long
but people seem to like it my original
supervisor emailed me with the message
i see that you slayed the beast and i
was so
happy that it had finally all worked out
so
of course it couldn't last i took a
break during the phd to work at
brilliant for a couple of months
this video isn't sponsored but if it was
that would be such a great segue into
the sponsored message
anyway i worked at brilliant for a few
months and i had the time of my life
but while i was there i realized that
there was a floor in this proof
after all right at the start i felt
so bad for my co-author because this was
a bit that i'd worked on alone before
they'd joined the project
so it was solely my fault that it was
wrong i felt terrible for my supervisor
and everyone else because
they had been so happy when i finally
finished it and i was upset for myself
not only would i not have this project
for my phd anymore
i'd have to retract a paper every time i
thought about that mistake
i felt like i was gonna vomit i kept
trying to fix it but i just
couldn't i thought what if i just don't
tell anyone
the mistake was in a very technical part
of the proof that no one would probably
notice wasn't right
but i knew i couldn't do that during the
phd i had read
other papers for ages only to discover
that the proof had a mistake in it
and it would infuriate me i couldn't do
that to someone else
so i resolved to just take the paper
down but
not before i gave it one last go at
fixing it when i returned
so i put the mistake out of my mind and
had an awesome time in america
when i finally went back to the uk i
went and worked on it again
and i managed to actually fix it in a
couple of weeks
leaving the problem for a while and
coming back to it gives a different
perspective and it apparently really
works
so yes the proof is correct as far as i
know
so here's the result this one clean
qubit model is a type of quantum
computer
that has a low amount of entanglement
and yet can outperform a classical
computer
we studied this computer when it had no
entanglement at all
my hypothesis was that entanglement
wasn't really being used in the original
model
so if you took all the entanglement out
i was pretty sure you'd still have
something better than a classical
computer
and it turned out that was totally wrong
somehow entanglement is crucial
even in this most unlikely candidate
which makes me think maybe entanglement
is the key to quantum computing
after all just to be clear i didn't show
that entanglement is the key to quantum
computing
that will take a whole lot of extra work
to show conclusively
but what i did manage to do is change my
mind about something that i really
believed
and that seemed like a pretty good
outcome to me